unverified footage appears to show an
object flying toward the Dome of the
Kremlin before bursting into flames one
of two drones brought down said the
Kremlin using electronic radar assets
the Russian president wasn't there at
the time according to his spokesman the
kremlin's Press office described the
incident as a planned terrorist act
vowing that Russia reserves the right to
take retaliatory measures where and when
it sees fit on a visit to Finland the
Ukrainian president flatly denied Kiev
had anything to do with it we don't
attack
Putin or Moscow
are we fight on our territory we are
defending our religious and cities U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken said
he had seen the reports I can't uh in
any way validate them we simply we
simply don't know